getting things fixed getting back to
normal and reopening the economy will
require three key things more testing to
catch outbreaks before they get out of
control contact tracing to identify
anyone an infected person came in
contact with and isolation to break the
chain of transmission test trace isolate
is the mantra and it's the tracing part
where the right to individual privacy
collides with the need to protect public
health South Korea has led the world in
successful contact tracing as Jeff
simple explains it's required some
trade-offs not everyone is comfortable
making South Korea offers a glimpse of a
brighter future
crowds returning to amusement parks
the movies even the airport as though
the country just woke up from a strange
dream it feels great to be out with my
family he says we are still cautious but
it looks like the containment efforts
are going well South Korea was one of
the first and hardest hit countries by
the kovat 19 pandemic but after two
months of strict social distancing on
Wednesday it relaxed the rules and since
then there have been almost no new cases
the government had prepared I think
that's the most important thing dr.
Jerome Kim is the head of the
international vaccine Institute he
points to his country's outbreak of
another coronavirus MERS in 2015 that
spurred the government to introduce new
emergency powers allowing it to harness
credit card records and smartphone GPS
locations to track and retrace the
movements of kovat 19 patients although
you're tracked you're still anonymous
and it's really the government and and
the people who might have been exposed
to find out the anonymized data is used
to identify hotspots and in smartphone
apps to alert users about cases nearby
really don't do well with this whoops so
that's the alarm
during our interview Lee's own smart
phone sounded an alarm alerting him that
a kovat 19 patient had visited his
neighborhood bar called King Club zero
at a specific time if you had a fever of
37.5 and we're going to work and you
knew that you'd been at kin Club zero
you know are you going for testing and
they pipe they probably would put you in
isolation similar apps have been
deployed in more than 25 countries from
Australia to the UK but what about
Canada we're ready to go we have a
product be deployed in matter of days
Daniel Lee's Vancouver based company
pitched their contact tracing app to
several provinces including Ontario
unfortunately we just didn't see the
traction on the public sector side for
the most part Canada is still doing
contact tracing the old-fashioned way
that health professionals and volunteers
calling the kovat 19 patients contacts
one by one so that we can connect with
them find out if any of them are
symptomatic get them tested otherwise
they need to be isolating and that's in
strategy we provide them but that system
is far from perfect first I got the call
from the hospital telling me I could
positive this Vancouver actor tested
positive and says health officials asked
him for a list of his contacts and then
and then they told her when I mean we
went to the gas station but an employee
at that gas station told global news
they never received a call from Public
Health and had no idea a kovat 19
patient had been there it's gonna
require many many many people to be able
to follow up with all of those positive
tests and that's a part where I think
were particularly vulnerable cuz no
Public Health Unit has the resources to
do that right now a contact tracing app
would automate that process but there's
a catch most of the apps on offer
require access to a smart phones GPS
location allowing the government to
track a person's movements and sparking
concerns over privacy if you know that
as of tomorrow the government has a
trace on everywhere I've been and all
the people I've come in contact with you
may not want to live in a country like
that for a contact tracing app to be
effective studies suggest at least 60%
of the population needs to opt in if you
have large slots of Canada that look at
these applications with suspicion that
look at these apps as injurious to their
way of living they will not use them but
a solution may be in sight Google and
Apple are now building a framework that
will allow contact tracing apps on their
devices to use Bluetooth technology the
Bluetooth signal would locate other
phones nearby that are running the same
app so say you'd visited a restaurant
and the person at the table next to you
were to test positive you'd receive an
alert but your data would be encrypted
and never leave your phone unless you
tested positive and concern
did apple has walked me through on two
occasions all of what they've done in
terms of the tack and the privacy
presenting features and no geolocation
data and everything and so I can give my
vote of confidence to it
download a beat race together turn on
your Bluetooth and make some apps like
the one released just last week in
Alberta already employ Bluetooth
technology but without software support
from the tech giant's they've been
plagued with problems really I think
most serious app developers at the
moment have to wait until Google and
Apple and lend their technical
infrastructure in their smartphones the
Google Apple app support should be ready
later this month but most governments in
Canada still have not authorized any
apps to use the technology health
experts warn the longer the wait the
greater the risk is we tend to be very
slow adopters of any new technology like
that we wait until the rest of the world
has done it and then we gingerly put our
toes into the water you know this could
be a good opportunity for us to be a bit
bolder I mean people if they don't know
by now they should know that their
location is being tracked on their phone
24/7 and most people have not turned off
the location switch on their phone and
it's used for all sorts of things right
now typically for marketing a if it's
used for marketing using it for good to
try to prevent deaths seems like a more
noble cause and so why wouldn't we be
okay with that
the more restrictions are lifted the
greater the need for contact tracing and
testing and experts warn Canada is
currently lacking in both
[Music]